yo wassup reject nation I'm Greg Alba
and I'm jibba jibba John Humphrey we
gonna watch Black Panther touch all uh
versus batman bruce wayne b Wayne yep
cartoon beatbox battle from verbal assay
mm-hmm I'm the one with the English you
are the English master one of our top
reward tiers on patreon is ever video
you asked us to check out or talk about
or do discussion on we must definitely
do and put up on the youtubes this day
comes to my good friend Jay did you get
that shirt you never told me anyhow
let's find out what this is all about is
this guys a very successful YouTube
channel good for you man make sure to go
subscribe to him as soon as you can hey
what's up guys it's do it to Reena for
this
that's amazing
he wasn't
okay and a height of six foot two inches
you can't hide because because
with over 10 styles of martial arts
training
he is vengeance but I'm going to be by
starting the battle
are you guys ready beatbox beatbox
battle okay
black panther you're going up first
usually the flat seven as our same
[Music]
that's complete
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
it's like spider-man you are can't even
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you guys thank you for watching car to
beat hot metal well we got a fight I
hear he's one was gwanmi dude you want
to know you live with bats
what's guano it's bat poop oh how do you
know because it's like said I don't know
there are various statistics about how
much of it appears on like canned goods
and stuff like that this house really
I'd remember it was like some random way
I learned that
that base seriously what one I'll friend
so I believe it means best what I should
just wait it yeah man she just waited
right there and watch the credits how do
we find out who won
when was this posted November 22nd 2018
there's got to be a winner now is there
another video on the channel or is this
the most recent one a few more days now
how do we vote in the comments for sure
Black Panther most certainly one
and even though I'm definitely a bigger
bat fan then I am a Black Panther fan he
undoubtedly won the match too many good
disses I thought
Batman's song was more catchy and would
probably listen to more often however
the disc game definitely belongs to BP
so you're saying you prefer Linkin
Park's place for my head to Michael
Jackson's smooth criminal well because
two challahs song was a smooth criminal
and Batman song was place for my head
well yes they have the same melody and
they borrowed the same all that but the
lyrics I'm talking about John Montone oh
yeah oh yeah I mean nothing beats the
whole thing about that man can't take
down a clown but he expects to take down
a king good that's a great dish like
Batman brought up how he lost a kill
monger but we all know he eventually
beat kill monger he killed kill monger
come on our died yeah Batman needs to
finish that movie Joker just keeps you
know coming back in the game and
outsmarting the bass you can't keep them
in prison or anything
and can't keep him in Arkham so I would
say that for sure black panther won that
fight yeah well in general I mean Black
Panther just has so much more resources
and much bigger team yeah you know so
even if it came down to like more than
just the two of them his odds are not
stacked in bats is favor I say man this
this video is edited wonderfully yeah I
love this style to it from beginning to
end you know and all like the quick
little reference isn't good it's like
kinetic and hyper but you don't miss
anything and sometimes you do videos
like this little tiny moments here or
there like something as funny as
bringing out a spray bottle for a hot
second felony attack at things like we
have there was doing those things aren't
easy to fly over someone's head cuz it's
moving so fast that you might not even
pick up on it the editing and the timing
of everything here is so wonderfully
done I love the animation mix-up because
it's really funny but it's also really
cool simultaneously he's managing to do
both I'm making fun of it but also still
making it look really cool and I like
the beatbox element to it because I've
seen a lot of things like epic Rap
Battles there's a lot of rap there's a
lot of like fictional rap battle
concepts of people will sometimes do on
YouTube or they'll branch out and do a
little sketch it's a rap battle but this
format playing on aces beatboxing skills
yeah part of the hook yeah yeah it was
it was like a cool MTV comic book show
yeah reminded me that it had all the
charms of a viral animated you know
animated video but with the sort of
Celebrity Deathmatch kind of a like it
really made me think of Celebrity
Deathmatch if that was about rapping
instead of yeah pummeling each other
yeah it had that kind of vibe and sort
of that sense of humor as well I also
think that Batman loses because he
needed Robin's help big time in the end
you know even though did have backup
even though the ladies of Wakanda the
warrior woman the dorm Elijah even
though they show up here they're they're
not coming on the mic you know where
Robin had to come on the mic
and Batman it's a technicality right
it's a sec nickel foul see there was no
established chloride team rules there
man gotta let us know bats you can't
just sneak them in I hope that our
choice prevails and that T'Challa goes
on to rap battle somebody else who
deserves it although you know if he was
pulling from my deeper comic book
references cuz let's be honest most
people don't really know Black Panthers
deep ro gallery where you can really
call on the the Gotham world and you
could really call on all the villains
and how he can't ever seem to putting
them away permanently he you know
there's more to pull from an insult Tom
whereas Black Panther what are you gonna
do make fun of his cat suit yeah it can
still do a whole bunch of really
powerful stuff yeah I just really feel
like Batman relied too much on cat up
insults and his song was only one song
whereas two challahs was a master yeah a
California lovin and smooth criminal
Batman brought up a good point about how
if the chawla doesn't have his
superpower stuff you know he's probably
not as great but the thing is black
panther does have the superpower stuff
and he's still got like a whole Legion
of people would say you know what Conda
is more fun than Gotham I would much
rather be yeah a traveling civilian
passing through Wakanda then I would be
through Gotham City any day of the week
yeah also you know what I love to how it
would cut back to the MC face expression
like the really really create a lot of
great angles like it really does feel
like a big live boxing yeah yeah I think
that you know it's cut well enough to
make it yeah seem like a real spectacle
thanks Jay for recommending this video
the Erb belays I appreciate this video
very much go subscribe to him as soon as
you can and J my friend originally from
the Dirty South as he calls it all the
way to San Francisco we signed and sent
you one of our shirts yup and you were
supposed to post it on Instagram or
something I knit that sure myself where
is that photo of you rocking that shirt
pics or literally didn't happen you know
how this work i neva set at you right
now yeah man I'm very I mean don't don't
fledge but I'm very upset at you but
don't own pledge yeah just you know stay
pledged and that's your punishment
that's your punish your tithe to the
Church of us
well mr. J I hope you have a good day no
matter how hard things get life is gonna
be okay take it all the way follow your
dreams and ambitions and make sure you
live up to that act of contrition by not
removing your pledge or else I'm gonna
push you off the ledge you got it buddy
no that rhymes like a rap battle battle
not too much of a hassle but do that
there's John's beatbox beat right there
you guys can subscribe to the react
nation click that notification bell and
we'll catch you on the flippety-flip